attention sur la piste les chevaux les
voitures les gens
faites gaffe l'approché délicat si la
piste n'est pas dégagé on met les gaz
[Musique]
miraflores un trou perdu dans la jungle
colombienne
quatre mille habitants un des fiefs de
la drogue et de la guérilla
la piste de miraflores est incroyable
parce qu'elle est en plein milieu de
l'amazonie colombienne c'est une piste
extrêmement nombreux les glissante
elle étend père et les rend plus de tri
la piste c'est la recentrage à droite
des habitations et à gauche il ya
l'hôpital la police et l'école des
routes
ici il n'y en a pas seul moyen de
transport et de ravitaillement
ces vieux dc 3 un avion toutes les 50
minutes
bourré de marchandises et d'aventuriers
regarder au fond y'a un avion qui
s'approche le tracteur sur la piste le
chariot les gens train de discuter
regarder la mue qui s'emballe
c'est vraiment dangereux c'est le
travers sa pays il faut remettre les gaz
immédiatement sinon c'est la mort
assurée
[Musique]
lorsque les avions ont atterri sur la
piste
les enfants courent derrière et un jour
il y aura sûrement un accident très
grave
voilà
et
[Musique]
les mines c'est de nous notre chouchou
tout le monde la connaît et on l'a fait
voyager gratuitement quand on peut
s'occuper de nous on l'a d'or pour ça
elle est comme une fée des pilotes je
les trouve très beau alors je légal
ce sont les gens que j'aime le plus
c'est une m'adore ils me font craquer
j'aimerais vraiment avoir influencé
pilotes
[Musique]
on
ce que je vivais en ville ma famille m'a
foutu dehors
mon enfant ma rejeter aussi savaient pas
où aller je dormais dans la rue avec mon
fils de huit mois et pour survivre je
suis venu à miraflores
cela fait 15 ans que je suis ici
on n'a que ça à l'époque c'était le boom
de la coca les gens ici étaient très
riches
j'avais tellement d'argent qu'il s'en
servait comme papier toilette et moi je
ramasse et les billets et ensuite je les
lave et c'est comme ça que j'ai survécu
au désastre
et là on nous parlera la famille
aujourd'hui je suis commerçant seulement
quelques vêtements il la nage mais je
m'en sors pas trop mal mais ça dure
tous les jours je me lève à 6h du matin
je pars avec mon petit sac de lingerie
au village je vends mes articles à tout
le monde mais surtout aux femmes pour
mes meilleurs clients de ce sont des
prostituées
elle m'en achète tous les jours et aller
[Musique]
je ne suis pas devenue prostituée
c'est grâce à mon fils il m'a donné du
courage
la prostitution ce n'est pas pour moi
[Musique]
c'est dans ce village il n'y a rien
d'autre que le sexe et l'alcool
[Musique]
il n'ira flores et entre 500 et 600
prostituées c'est très dangereux pour
elle parce qu'il n'ya pas de loi ou
plutôt c'est la loi du plus fort la
famille ou entre amis j'ai beaucoup
d'amis prostituée qui sont fait tuer
pour avoir refusé un client c'est très
courant j'avais un petit ami et elle
buvait toi un jour il m'a pointé son
revolver sur la tête j'ai pensé que
j'allais mourir si vous m'avez tué que
serait devenu mon fils
ici à miraflores
nous avons de tout la violence trafic de
drogue policy à la guérilla des moeurs
et la prostitution
gladys 46 ans la proxénète de miraflores
une centaine de filles sous sa
protection
aucune mise à flot de la malaria florès
la plupart des femmes viennent
travailler comme serveuse dans les
cafétérias et dans les restaurants mais
s'aperçoivent que les prostitués gagnent
bien mieux leur vie alors il faut comme
les autres dans la prostitution ce
week-end où vous tu allais à pueblo
nuevo à cannes au ticket à los lagos et
pas nous agressent où veux tu allais
geipan nombreux moyens aussi bien en ce
moment
bon je t'envoie pueblo nuevo sur mon
carnet le nom défi que je vois dans
l'équipement forêt à pablo nous éveille
ailleurs je note avec soin les noms de
chacune
[Musique]
miraflores est un lieu de passage et de
perdition où l'argent coule à flots ceux
qui ont trimé des mois durant dans les
plantations de coca viennent ici flamber
leurs économies l'alcool le jeu les
filles
[Musique]
la nuit on en profite aussi pour régler
ses comptes en toute impunité
dans ce village il ya des quatre morts
par jour l'an dernier en ce moment ça va
un peu mieux
il y en a quatre par mois hier soir nous
prenons quelques bières
je ne sais pas que mon copain avec les
dettes
quelqu'un a tiré je suis parti en
courant mais j'ai été touché et mon ami
été tués
[Applaudissements]
la strata populaire que les filles sont
traités comme des animaux ici la vie
d'une femme ne vaut rien personne ne
l'est pas elles ne peuvent plus compter
sur elle même
moi je suis comme une merde à chacune
d'entre elles
j'essaie de les aider de faire attention
qu'il n'arrive rien qu'ça mes enfants
aussi
[Musique]
agassi a promis la floride ce couteau
j'ai toujours sur moi c'est ma seule
défense s'installe à voir si un prêt
pour qu'elle regarde
[Musique]
pour tenter d'éliminer les vingt-quatre
mille hectares de champs de coca du
département le gouvernement colombien a
lancé un nouveau programme de fumigation
au glyphosate un herbicide destructeur
classifiés hautement toxique par les
états unis
l'épandage de ce désherbant a provoqué
la colère des populations locales
je m'appelle thomas ce alberto rodado je
vis est bien florès depuis environ huit
ans et j'appartiens à un comité dont il
fut milhas sion nous luttons tous contre
ce programme du gouvernement nous fait
que polluer détruire l'environnement
ici c'est le poumon du monde à
miraflores les paysans ne peut vivre que
de la coca ils n'ont pas d'autre choix
que la coca c'est pas trop tôt on avait
commencé un mort de faim
puis comme le gouvernement colombien qui
nous a toujours délaissées et
aujourd'hui on s'intéresse à nous mais
pour venir nous polluer qu'est ce que tu
veux qu'on plante ici on peut même pas
semer du maïs c'est pas rentable
le riz c'est pire alors on cultive la
coca l'état ne donne pas d'argent
de toute façon on n'a pas d'autres
cultures de substitution qui rapporte
autant que la coca la coca sera toujours
un produit supérieur au reste ça
rapportera toujours plus
la nettoie une mine qu'en penses tu moi
je n'ai qu'une seule chose à dire je ne
suis pas d'accord avec ces fumigation
qui contaminent l'environnement
elles détruisent aussi les cultures de
caoutchouc le cacao les bananes on
devrait les interdire ont de toute façon
il n'existe pas d'autres cultures pour
faire vivre la région et pour le moment
on n'a pas d'autre alternative et le
gouvernement lui n'a jamais rien fait
pour nous c'est vrai il nous prend pour
des cocus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là je sais pas les costumes on en
[Musique]
bon
est ce qui me laisse à l'extérieur on
appelle miraflores mis la côte on nous a
accusés de faire partie d'un arc en
guérilla mais nous ne sommes ni des
guerriers rose ni des trafiquants
nous sommes seulement des paysans
cultivons la coca et c'est différent si
tu vend des chaussures contre les achète
avec l'argent de la cocaïne compagnies
aériennes qui envoie ses avions ici tous
les vols sont pays produit de la côte
bien sûr il ya aussi des éleveurs des
gens qui produisent d'autres cultures
mais ça ne rapporte pas suffisamment on
ne peut pas vivre correctement soignés
beaucoup de gens aiment miraflores c'est
le rêve amical nous pensent qu'ils vont
faire fortune mais la réalité est
différente
ici on ne s'enrichit pas une vie bien
c'est tout on travaille la terre si les
gens l'opportunité de trouver les moyens
de subsistance qu'il n'aurait pas pu
trouver un boulot
un laboratoire clandestin comme il en
existe des centaines dans la région si
90% des cultivateurs produisent de la
cocaïne base la pasta qu'ils revendent
aux trafiquants la drogue était ensuite
expédiés par bateau ou en avion vers
d'autres laboratoires plus sophistiqués
pour y être raffiné puis exportés vers
l'europe et les états unis
ses feuilles ont déjà été haché
on s'apprête à le faire
on ramasse les feuilles on les mélange
avec de la chaux puis on les laisse
macérer dans celui dont on en 40 minutes
la lignée du kérosène mélangé à 2 litres
d'eau et on n'ajoute aucun centilitres
d'acide
après on rajoute de l'ammoniac pour
séparer la coca et ça l'a fait blanchir
maintenant on peut la filtrer avec ce
torchon
ce qui reste c'est la base la pasta
et combien ça souvent ici à miraflores à
peu près 10 francs le gramme
là il ya au moins 150 g donc 1500 francs
par hectare pour qu'on produit environ
un kilo ce qui rapporte 10 mille francs
mais comme j'ai eu huit mille francs de
frais il ne me reste que deux mille
francs de bénéfice sont les
intermédiaires qui l'expédient à
l'étranger qui gagnent beaucoup d'argent
parce que nous réellement gagne presque
rien juste de quoi vivre et de charges
et et quelques cadeaux pour noël
comme c'est bientôt l'été il n'y aura
pas de récolte pour notre monnaie et on
n'aura pas un sou
miraflores et le département du guaviare
produisent 60 % de la coca de colombie
c'est 13 % de la production mondiale
l'équivalent de 150 tonnes de cocaïne
base par an un vrai pactole qui fait
vivre des dizaines de milliers de
familles dans la région les fumigations
les gens d'ici ne veulent plus en
entendre parler
mini et l'ontario nette domination
lorsque les avions de la police est
intervenue ici tout le village envahi la
piste pour les empêché d'atterrir et un
site se ravitailler en carburant
notre grève s'est étendue au reste de la
région et du pays car nous les paysans
de la jungle
nous n'allons pas nous laisser mourir de
faim on a tous des enfants
je pense que dans toute la région de
miraflores
il doit y avoir plus de cent mille
personnes qui dépendra coca
le commandant en chef de l'armée
colombienne m'a traitée de narco
irrigants ici en colombie
c'est comme s'il m'avait condamné à la
peine de mort moi je ne sors jamais la
nuit pour éviter une embuscade le jour
au moins je pourrai voir celui qui va me
tuer
à miraflores les affrontements avec
l'armée sont réguliers c'est la chasse
gardée de la guérilla des farc
ces rebelles on les surnomme narco
guérilla hausse parce qu'ils taxent
toutes les activités dédiées à la coca
récolte laboratoire transport et pistes
clandestines
racket qui rapporte gros et qui permet
d'alimenter la rébellion ce conflit qui
dure depuis près de 40 ans et qui a déjà
fait de nombreuses victimes a peu de
chances d'aboutir
trop d'intérêts sont en jeu
voit sa vérité dans leurs tranchées ça
devient dangereux là parfois ils
bombardent le village
et thouaré si parfois c'est comme un
petit vietnam
bilan de la journée à mort et six
blessés côté militaire si le maire de
miraflores décret numéro 189 de l'année
1994 par ce présent décret le couvre-feu
est imposé
ainsi que l'interdiction de vente et de
consommation d'alcool
[Musique]
ricardo le fils de mimouna 14 ans il vit
en pension à villavicencio à une heure
de vol de miraflores sa mère il ne la
voit quasiment pas une fois par mois
tout au plus lorsque yvan le pilote
l'embarquent dans son désir 3
emine steinlin surprise regarde mon fils
travaille et envir dans un club de
tennis mais je préférerais qu'il
étudiait il passe son bac qu'il me dise
maman je voudrais avoir un bon métier
j'aimerais vraiment qu'ils deviennent
quelqu'un je ne voudrais pas qu'il tombe
dans ces histoires de drogue
j'en ai vu des gosses des jeunes de 16
ou 17 ans mourir de sa moi je n'ai
jamais voulu semer de la coca parce que
je pense à mon fils et que lui aussi
pourrait en mourir
[Musique]
pour envoyer l'argent de la pension à
mon fils je passe par cette radio qu'on
appelle radio condor bakary comme il
n'ya pas de bons qu'ici c'est notre
radio qui effectue les virements dans
tout le pays
on envoie en moyenne entre 40 et 50 bus
seront pas rejoints trois coréens nis au
corps et à l'esprit le respect des
eyquems il avouera également là
[Musique]
omer s40 c'est pour mon fils que je
supporte tout cela et l'espérance c'est
mon espoir il va grandir va faire et
être un petit bien
j'espère pouvoir un jour mon année d'ici
quitter ce village pour toujours
[Musique]